una comisión independiente Que investigó
Durante un año casos de abuso sexual
cometidos por miembros de la Iglesia
Católica de Portugal reveló el informe
final de su trabajo en el cual el
estudio casos ocurridos Durante los
últimos 70 años dentro de escuelas
católicas casas de sacerdotes
confesionarios entre otros
como supuesto explicar con estos
testimonios como explicaremos más
adelante con detenimiento nos permiten
llegar a una red de víctimas mucho más
extensa calculada en un número mínimo de
4,815 víctimas
según los hallazgos el 77% de los
perpetradores eran sacerdotes y casi
todas las víctimas eran hombres además
la mayoría de los menores fueron
abusados repetidamente desde uno y hasta
siete años en algunos casos el informe
también denuncia el silencio que guardó
la iglesia católica de Portugal la
comisión inició su trabajo en enero del
año pasado tras conocerse un informe en
Francia que reveló que unos 3000
sacerdotes y funcionarios religiosos
abusaron sexualmente a más de 200.000
niños la Iglesia Católica ha dicho
anteriormente que estaba preparada para
tomar las medidas pertinentes el hecho
es que no es una realidad en todas
partes y eso es lo que debemos hacer
Mirando al pasado lo que se ha cometido
en términos de delitos y haciendo lo que
podamos en términos de prevención y
protección creo que la iglesia en
Portugal también como muchos otros
países está comprometida con estas dos
tareas
el trabajo de este equipo concluyó pero
los expertos pidieron a la iglesia
portuguesa que cree otra comisión
similar para dar un seguimiento por su
parte la conferencia episcopal recibió
el informe y aseguró que analizará la
situación en una asamblea extraordinaria